i'm sorry i interrupted the you pushing
your hammer no it's okay we can talk
about it later
no i don't think we should talk like
that's gross we don't need to do it yet
we'll be growing no shame to hemorrhoids
but
i just think you're just as a hemorrhoid
she actually had a twin and she was the
hammer and the twin died
[Laughter]
i gotta go home to masturbate twenty
december
i gotta move back in with my family are
you having a
cameltoe right now
[Music]
yeah i i don't know i like being made
fun of by people that i know like me
like if i know you like i know you like
me say you ever you want
like i don't care nothing can make me
think you don't like it because it's not
a hit it's just like uh we're hanging
out we're making jokes like it's not
like but that's part of why i want to do
this podcast
is because i know i've told you guys
this but like i have
strong memories of seeing male comedians
speak in interviews and say like you
know women are funny but like the thing
about guys is that like
we can be mean to each other and girls
can't do that and i'm just sitting there
watching that at home like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about like
women can't be mean to each other
and like i almost feel like i've been
wearing that on uh
like i've just been living in that
interview moment that i saw because i
and trying to like
spend my life proving it wrong i need my
female friends to make fun of me i need
to [ __ ] make fun of them
that's not a guy's only thing maybe
typically
but not anymore like no i want people to
see us how did this all come about
when did you two become friends let's
let's roll it back a couple of years
and true hollywood story yeah this is
our true hollywood story how did this
start how did this friendship start okay
so i
like i feel like annie and i were at a
place in comedy where we both kind of
knew
who the other one was and i like had
heard she'd come to the comedy store
and she got passed right away and i was
really excited to meet her because she's
just like young
hot funny comics i'm like ooh like i
want to see her boobs or something
so i saw her in the hallway disappointed
you must have been
i saw her in the hallway and like right
away i just like locked eyes with her
and i
i think i what did i i think i pulled
your shirt off
i believe you pulled my tits out or you
pulled yours out like i
i remember feeling like you were trying
to
like shock me and i was like [ __ ] wrong
girl and like pulled my tits out too or
pulled yours out right
yeah i just felt like oh i know this
girl is gonna be down i can just tell
from her energy like there is no
shocking her like i just knew that i
i could tell but we had the same manager
so we both had this manager back in the
day
our first one of our first daddies
hi hollywood daddy um sorry we fired
i just can't believe your a person we
fired
no it's fine it's fine it's fine but he
so when i saw you at the comedy store
you're very obvious
who you are because he had sent me your
your like reel at one point
and then i watched a bunch of your stuff
and you're so little and your name was
little esther that it wasn't like i was
gonna forget
who you were your name or anything so i
remember going up to you and going
oh we have the same manager and then you
were great i mean the tits were out
immediately
it was fast friends yeah it was fast
friends and it was also
fast enemies because this story takes a
turn
so kala it could be you one day i can't
wait for that day
but also i i hope it's a long time from
now
yeah well you know what i want to know
is what is your what are your early
memories of me because i also remember
clicking with you right away like
seven or eight years ago whatever it was
when i was do opening for bobby at the
irvine improv and it was the first time
i met you
and i just i remember liking you right
away
knowing not to be too too aggressive but
and then i
and then imagine thinking when you meet
someone of like
what the move is just imagine being like
i don't want to come on too much of this
or that
oh she's look at her just kind of
planning at all
but then i learned you were a nurse so
you were so i'm like oh she's
what just the idea that i just imagined
you financially as a nurse
like sweet now i can complain to her
about all my ailments and that's been
our entire friendship
that was kind of our beginning too and
then when i was in on a tour in
australia new zealand and i got sick i
just remember i was texting with you
every day and you were helping me and i
was like
i just was like oh me and kyle are like
we're in this forever
wait but i need to know what is your
first memory of me like do you have any
yeah the first the first thing you said
to me you didn't introduce yourself
you didn't say who you were i i went
into the green room and you're like do
you want to see my boobs
do you remember that you have one move
but you because you're calculated you
knew to
with her to ask and with me you just
assaulted me
but you didn't ask to see mine in return
but i know i was trying i was dangling
for it
that was my tactic did i get to see your
boobs are you gonna come out in the
first episode are we gonna like
tease it for a while um i don't think
you've ever
i now regret never showing you my fake
boobs because you don't have any
reference for
what they look like before and what
disaster
how disastrous they look now there's no
way they looked at that
well consider this i had double d's
smashed into little a cups
there is some stretch there is stretch
but i guess
it's probably not bad but i guess
because i only had them for two years um
the skin kind of like held up its
integrity do you want to
show me in the back room and when i can
come back and say what i think
like why does that have to be a back
room like it's so creepy
it can't be a front room it has to be a
back room oh you're
so that's how esther and i met were you
threatened by me and all were you like
oh
keep her away from my man
did you like me did you what did you
think i just thought that
you were as close of a version to bobby
as i'd ever met because i'd met other
comics at that point and i was like huh
bobby sort of like stands in his own
lane he is just this
he is just who he is until i met you i
was like oh
they're the same kind they're cut from
the same cloth so you thought she's
calling you fat
so so you thought i was a lot like your
boyfriend
yes okay and so i felt very what's the
opposite of the most
threatened secure very very
i wouldn't even say secure i just felt
very um
okay with your existence in the green
room thank you
and immediately i found you really funny
really yeah because i saw yourself oh
she's look she's
she saw yourself that's really now that
was she riffing i can't imagine it was
her jokes
annie on the other hand i was super
intimidated by it well when did we first
meet i remember seeing you at the coming
show but i don't know if we met maybe we
never got introduced until we did the
tiger belly
okay properly but i had seen you there
maybe twice
and i remember you wearing all black
with like a black leather jacket
yeah my friend your skin was like
snatched to the heavens your eyes had a
really perfect like
upturned angle you had a really like you
had a lot of bass in your voice and i
was like oh gosh i need to
stay away and this is this is a slow
this is going to this is going to happen
slowly and organically i can't force it
isn't that interesting her first
instinct was stay away is it interesting
her first instinct was you remind me of
my
asian boyfriend
and um so yeah i remember thinking holy
[ __ ]
is she i remember asking bobby i was
like is she uh
just a super hot girl who's someone's
girlfriend or is she a comic because i
couldn't imagine
i was like if i booked the club a super
hot
girl this is so fun you know i always
thought i was ugly until recently
annie you when i first met you i was
like she can't cannot possibly be
a comic you look too put together well
luckily
a lot of men in my life when i was a
child also thought i thought i was super
hot
so that is why i get to become a comic
now and let's ring the bell and he was
molested everyone
welcome to the show and only a couple
times by esther
here's the thing well because my mom i
guess was pimping me out i know my mom
took those pictures i'm like i saw the
picture i'm like
they're cute but they're like a little
bit they're really very sexy
they're very sexy guys i'm five in the
pictures we're talking about
it seemed like there was always a breeze
a breeze in all your pictures your hair
is always flowing in the wind
well i was running a lot of times
screaming for help so maybe that's what
it was
so did you really get pimped out no no
well my no my mom just
my parents were are quaker and like
really
very nice to people and always want to
give people chances so sometimes that
put me in some dangerous situations
because they didn't want to like
if let's just say like if there was a
babysitter that everyone's like well
you're not like i had boy babysitters i
had a lot of boy babysitters which like
who has boys
babysitter with his pants unzipped
did i tell you this story he was asleep
and his pants were unzipped and he
wasn't wearing underwear so we went and
put got ice and put it in his
thing but i never the story was always
just funny that we put ice on a dick
i never none of my brothers and i have
like stopped to be like why was jeremy's
penis out
was his penis out yeah it was unzipped
and i think it was out i mean i don't
maybe
well maybe would have peeked in maybe he
fell asleep
jerking off no with his with his um fly
down
and then when you fall asleep you get a
version of morning wood
and so maybe it just sort of grew out of
the unzipped
i'm trying to defend you but also my
parents their porns got stolen by
i think it was a his friend who also
babysat so i think what was happening
was
the that jeremy came over found the
porns
your parents had porns yeah and we all
stole them my parents did too
we all stole them not of themselves well
they did make one of themselves but they
said they smashed it with a hammer
because it was so disgusting
they said it just looked like two fat
people [ __ ] horrifying they just
smashed it with a hammer
i how can you even handle knowing that i
don't like that at all
that makes me very uncomfortable
thinking of your parents as sexual
beings
i feel like that's almost i mean it's
not
the thing i want to see or talk about
but i want to honor them
as once upon a time young virile
and highly sexual because one day
imagine people talking to us
talking about us like this i'd be
heartbroken but also if you think i was
thinking about this today like weddings
and stuff like you know when dads are
like don't
date my daughter but it's like no you
want to carry on your name right that's
you need someone to date your daughter
and [ __ ] your daughter and have a
and jizz and your daughter all right and
get married to your daughter so that you
your name cares you you need that were
you born in india
if you do that no way but then you take
their last name so never mind you need
your son dowry you need your sons to i
do anna can i
can i jizz in your the daughter in
between your legs
yes with what
my jib i want you to squeeze your vagina
oh god oh god
okay so but no wait but what i was
thinking was if you're
i always thought i was gross thinking
about my parents having sex too but then
i was like no
your parents are like i mean not always
but sometimes parents are in the room
when they're giving birth and stuff i
mean that is j that was a jizz moment
and a baby was born somehow i
should hold for your household
what if they threw supplies down to us
right now and we just didn't know what
was going on in the world
isn't that how spam came to be it was
like a military food
do you guys are you guys not on board
with spam but no i'm on board with spam
this
are you on board with spam i was well
look i'm a vegetarian now but
hell yeah on my meet days close to my
period i'm a spam girl
i'm an island girl what does it taste
like joy
it is pretty good i don't think you guys
quite understand
the value system for the rest of the
world in regards to spam
spam is something that i have to bring
in bulk
when i go back to the philippines
because it is to them
like better than chocolate if i go back
to the philippines and i don't have cans
of spam
in a box ready for them ready to gift to
them
it's it's not going to be a happy
homecoming isn't it mystery meat it's
like
all different meats ground up until that
is my hope see my hope is that it's just
byproduct
my hope is that it's [ __ ] they didn't
want that they
made delicious and didn't put to waste
well that's what scrapple is that's like
a philadelphia
food it's the best it's all the scraps
from a pig it's like pig ass all those
things and it's the most delicious thing
you've ever had
they fry it so it's like crispy on the
outside and still like
it has the consistency of liver even
though i hate the taste of liver but
it's got the consistent liver on the
inside it's so good that's another thing
that
americans don't value chicken scrap
liver gizzard we do we have esther in
our pockets
we eat that as like a main course back
home well hot girls eat bone broth now
and that's like where they take all the
extra bones
the collagen in it right yeah and they
they boil it i've made bone broth
so at least our hot girls are using the
bones
in america is like ew you eat stuff
that's not sugar fish every day and if
you don't live in l.a sugar fish is just
the most expensive delicious
sushi i just don't eat meat so when
we're like even just already talking i
i would never eat pork anyone just
talking about i'm like okay i don't want
like i don't judge it but then when i
were talking about like
chicken [ __ ] you don't like to eat
that's what you're saying
little piggy i don't eat my own okay
pigs will eat each other they don't give
a [ __ ] pigs the chicken eat
each other that's how i knew that's
basically how i can justify
consuming chicken on like the one day
out of the month that i
eat meat it's because i used to own
chickens and my last chicken named coco
his name was kukuk i had him for seven
years
he died because my aunt um was really
angry that he was pooing everywhere in
the backyard as chickens do
so she caught off his leg and he bled to
death on my sister's birthday
but cool cook would eat anything i gotta
go
and we would feed him chicken scraps he
eat chicken scraps so that's why i was
like you know if you're gonna eat your
own i think it's okay
if i eat you sometimes why didn't she
just break its neck or something she
wanted it to suffer
she was cr cracked out of her mind
she my aunt is was
a living cockroach human cockroach oh is
she still alive
no she so esther you're the number one
human cockroach
and she was my godmother believe it or
not you know what she did this [ __ ] did
to me
on my birthday when i was eight years
old she gave me a gold necklace
and when i fell asleep i was so happy
i'd never owned a piece of jewelry
before
when i went to sleep she took it off of
my neck and she pawned it
and when i woke up and i didn't have it
anymore she got mad at me
for losing the necklace it wasn't until
like a year later when my mom um was
like no she pondered
she took it right off your neck isn't
that like child abuse
yeah but that's that's that's my whole
childhood speaking of
you paying for her funeral i feel like
the funeral business is such a racket
i feel like the funeral business is
evergreen forever and we should get on
board
invest well i think we should start a
mortuary
instead of this podcast yeah this should
be that is forever
and then we don't know we do the podcast
and we start the mortuary and we
it's like a this podcast is sponsored by
our funeral
or we say our podcast bombed now let us
embalm you no but it's a racket because
this is my dad always tells the story of
like when his parents passed away and he
had to
he always tells that story it's such a
delightful fun
story maybe do you always tell the story
about the leg bleeding out
you i can tell you dude because you told
it fast yeah it's one of those
traumatizing stories that you just have
to say really like you have all the
beats you've said it so many times
nobody he talks about how like his
parents died and
they the funeral person like they take
you and they walk you through they're
like you can buy this casket or this
casket or this cat's kit and they like
prey on your sadness
and he said he's like i wasted all this
money on like the best
cherry wood casket he's like don't do
that for me
give me the cheapest stuff like he i
think he's just like cheap and
we just know it needs to be big enough
that you can fit in it too because
you're gonna
throw yourself in there with them i mean
and by the way your dad thinking that
when he dies that you're gonna have
anything to do with any of it you're
going to be
all of a sudden you're going to take the
reins i'm going to be making calls
were you about to say you're going to be
the killer let me tell you what my dad
ended up in
we so we went to a mortuary in pasadena
and um we were so broke at this time my
sister and i went back
were were in college we were swimming my
mom was
this is before she went back to nursing
school so we were flat [ __ ] broke
so my dad we received his ashes bought
back in a cardboard box
and inside that cardboard box was just a
little little bag like a plastic bag
and then um we laughed for two straight
hours when we got it
like we were in the funeral home cry
laughing like on the floor because it
was so
[ __ ] sad and pathetic but that's
funny that you're like this is our dad
yeah yeah and then one of the other
things was they were like oh is there
anything combustible in his body
and i was like well no because he didn't
have like a pacemaker nothing right
and i didn't realize that like my dad
had like an
old bullet lodged in his like rib
or something like that from when you
were a teenager
because he would he worked in you know
my dad was born in 1924.
but he worked in like espionage work
that's why he was a linguist he spoke
eight languages
he traveled the world did [ __ ] that i'm
not even privy to
um but he had a bullet lodged and
apparently it was highly combustible
stuff
i don't know but they were like oh did
you know this part and you're like oh
maybe we just didn't tell you i would be
like give me the bullet
yeah and so i they give you this little
ring around the
when they tie up the ashes so i wore
that as a
as a necklace was your dad d.b cooper
who's stevie cooper oh my god he's like
the guy that
hijacked a plane and got away with it
and then okay
i just want to let everyone know a
documentary just came out about this
person and that's how esther knows what
this is
it's not like she knew this for a long
time wait did you know richard ramirez
before nightcrawler
oh personally yes i did too wait no she
knew who he was personally he was she
was the only one he was like i'm good
oh are you talking about the night
stalker night stalker oh nice stalker uh
no i'm i'm very much well versed on the
golden state killer but not the night
stalker
the golden state griller that's pretty
good that's pretty neat
thank you okay so go back to db cooper
d.b cooper hijacked the play
he hijacked a plane i think in like the
80s does anyone know oh
and he doesn't even know the numbers and
he's the only guy like back in the 80s
like people were just hijacking planes
it was pretty fun but they always got
caught but he got away with it and
nobody knew who he was and there's all
these people out there who like i know
who d.b cooper was
were there people on the plane yes but
but
i didn't know this is very cool they
landed
while he was hijacking it they landed it
and then the
the flight attendant who d.b cooper like
you know was had
holding hostage or whatever she was like
can we just let all the passengers off
the plane and he's like yeah
and all the passengers got to leave the
plane and it would then
they flew back up and it was the flight
flight crew and the
pilots and then where did it end up
landing
was there switzerland involved no no
what happened was is they flew back up
they go
i think they brought they landed they
brought him his money they got the
passengers off they flew back up in the
air and then he jumped out
and he's still at large yeah so guys if
you want to just
watch this episode you can find out all
about this or you can have the actual
facts
in the documentary esther was half
asleep when she watched
no i wasn't half asleep but i did watch
it over the course of like seven meals
oh what were they sugar fish sugar fish
sugar fish
um i i know that we all watched night
stalker this year i didn't watch the
whole thing because i got a little bit
you didn't i was fully invested in gail
carrillo
i loved it i loved he's an l.a boy like
a true angelino
born and raised in the streets like he
he was my hero from the start you know
how he the
the other older detective sal palerno or
whatever the only
older guy that he um partnered up with
um
he was supposed to be like the big shot
in la the big
murder cop but it was gill i liked that
part when he was
when he asked him to be his partner and
he had to play cool
it's like when esther and i called you
to see if you would do the podcast with
us
oh that's right any chance chance you
might you might
wanna do a power no this is what esther
said esther did not take that approach
at all
she's like if you say no don't feel bad
we have many other options
i didn't say that i would never say
other options we also did not have other
options
who else just so you know annie and i
we've okay
and i've been talking about doing a
podcast for literally 2 000
i have i have emails since 2013. and
we started talking about it a lot again
this past year because we've been
guesting on each other's podcasts and
those episodes always get the most views
and so we've been talking talking about
it but we are so
vile together we've we just we couldn't
do it right because we just
would hate each other and then one night
annie was like
i wonder if like kalyan would ever clyde
would never do it
and i just look at her i was like i
think she would and he was like no she
wouldn't i know she wouldn't and i was
like oh
are you sure we had just been on the
phone for like seven hours and are
getting to know each other
facetime and you had you were like you
need to do a girls podcast
you're like george really george the
producer really wants me to do one but
i don't know and they were like i just
really don't want to do another podcast
you just said it so many times that i
was like
it would have been disrespectful at that
point i thought she was
so so she goes i wish clay would do it
and i'm like clyde i'm like
let's do that let's do it no no no she
will never do it a week goes by
and finally i'm like let's just call her
right now i just okay
i just felt like i was like it's kalila
she's gonna say yes i don't know why i
thought that
and then we called you and bobby said
yes first
yeah that actually did feel good when
bobby said yes bobby said yes
and then i i went home and then i
immediately called george
and um i was like what do you think
because he's been pushing for me to do
an all girls podcast for a long time
and he's you know given me options
different pairing options and i've
shot them all down and this was the
first one where i was like
oh yeah i just talked to annie for five
hours and that was the easiest thing i'd
done
that was the easiest friendship yeah
that was so the quickest friendship
i'd ever made in the last you know
couple years
and and so i thought hmm okay let me see
it
um and what were you thinking about me
the truth is i felt
really really flattered and honored that
was my true feeling it was almost like
wait why are you guys choosing me
there's so many it's so funny you're
the way we view you and how you do
yourself is so
off i think it's because i
i really truly think like and i'm not
just saying this
but you guys are the two funniest
my favorite comics it doesn't mean as
much when you say her too
but i'll take it because but it's like
you guys's brand is so different but
somehow like meshes
perfectly together and i would watch you
guys on any well
on each other's podcasts and bobby would
too and bobby
never watches anything oh my god wow
well we are we're an odd couple for
sure like we are she makes me very
uncomfortable
um she's very aggressive and disgusting
and very quiet and disgusting esther
the fact that she bathed for this was
the big thing was that she was going to
bathe for the podcast
yeah and i i feel like we're an odd
couple and you're
you're your own thing i feel very
kindred with you though i feel like we
have
like a lot of annie that's because i i
truly
think like i don't know if i believe
in um reincarnation but i think you were
outfit set screams i believe in
reincarnation
but i truly think you were um
one of my asian uncles in a package i
love
it am i asian you are a japanese
boy thank you but i think that maybe
a japanese like boy ghost oh yes
bobby is the bobby like labeled me and
i'm this is i always been my label now
he says i'm an 18 i i have the social
skills of an 18th century ghost
and i'm like yeah that's a fit that you
just watched
in the 18th century in the 18th century
by the way people
really knew what they were doing they
used their use their hands they were far
more like
industrious and real craftsmen that's
one of the reasons why
that's like my favorite role play is
always 1800s
no 1700s because before that they didn't
use their hands
everything was like bobbing for apples
you do century-based
wait you do century-based role-playing
yeah you have to really go back in time
you look at you look like you look at
the whole stretch of history
and then you choose a point in time and
then you use that as
as you know a jump off historical
historical rules you have to do research
beforehand
no you guys yes a little bit i've been
a 1700 shoemaker like i've gone
he's a boy no no no no no i swear like
i'm i'm the i'm always the boy
i go house to house and with my all in
hammer
and then i measure feet and then bobby
is
one of the aristocrats that i'm fitting
that day it's a woman he's a woman or a
boy he's a woman
and i'm i'm making i'm making her a clog
that day because i'm
i'm making a [ __ ] i'm making a a clog
for a fancy aristocratic woman
there's there's nothing creepier than
wanting a roleplay as a [ __ ]
aristocrat
that is so creepy to me but she gave him
that role
yeah he wasn't like i don't know whose
idea who who's
fetish who got offered his idea no
no actually it was bobby's i knew he
started he he made me
the shoemaker of course yeah he's never
in
who casts themselves as a door-to-door
clog fixer
in a [ __ ] sex act
that is so weird his creative mind it
all goes to these role play scenarios
what's what else and it doesn't show up
anywhere else
[Laughter]
and then i have to he shows me his bad
foot her bad foot
because she's a woman in this no that's
a joke right no she's
like look what do you think of this and
then i have to hold
um his you know would you know which
foot i'm talking about i don't know if
you guys are aware we should probably
tell our audience bobby has
what i call a green foot and it's been
riddled
with fungus for years
and it just doesn't look good i didn't
know that but i knew that that
knew it yeah so i we were
we come up with a more what i think is
like
um a breathable clog so that is
so you are inventing even when he puts
you in this role
yeah he puts you in this role as just
like this [ __ ] person that's to deal
with his
and then you become an inventor yeah
look at that one of the greatest minds
of the 17th century one of the greatest
minds of that role play
what other historical role play esther's
getting horny look at her stance
um it depends like pick an era do you
want to go pre
like do you want to go like dinosaur
ages no
you really you do not have that yeah we
have caveman well not
this i guess that's um no we don't have
dinosaur ages esther because there were
no humans then
over dinosaurs i've only ever done very
simple like
role play where i'm neighborhood girl oh
prettier than
me girl i we don't we've never gotten
fancy like very simple when you've been
together well we've been together for
eight years
you have to get creative you can't keep
[ __ ] the same person
you know what i mean like i can't i
can't have sex with him as bobby anymore
he has to be someone new
imagine just him as bobby i don't think
i could do it
i'm just thinking about if i've like
ever seriously role-played before
i mean i've definitely had my own little
fantasies in my head but i remember with
my ex-boyfriend the first time we [ __ ]
we had been friends for a long time
and the first time and he'd always been
really nice and the first time we [ __ ]
he was like you little [ __ ] [ __ ] i
was like whoa
whoa see okay we should probably talk
about this then
army hammer oh yeah
yeah it's it's very weird i i
hear i don't want to kink shame anybody
but give us a quick synopsis first i'm
totally down to king shame people but i
don't feel like this is
army hammer we see leaked dms that he's
basically saying things like
i want to suck your blood while i fall
asleep and like get your minerals out of
your body and that
he says he ate a animal's heart he he
cut an animal's heart out of its body
and ate it while it was still warm and
he said that he wanted to eat this
woman's heart
and he wanted he goes i'm 100
a cannibal it's hard to admit that but i
am so something like that you know
and here's the insight i got from my
therapist because we have
our couple's counselor at least she said
definitively
that who you are in your bedroom has
nothing to do
and should have nothing to do with who
you are outside of it
fantasy is just that it's fantasy and
there should be a very clear line
but esther is you are right esther in
the sense that
i think that you can let's say you have
a really messy divorce with somebody
they can't use that in court to smear
your
character and say he was into
cannibalism
they can't use that they can yeah well
my reference is the daily mail so i
don't know how reliable this is but i'm
told like in divorce proceedings that
that can be a thing where
they they bring in your your bedroom
ethics well you know they probably over
the years have done that to women like
oh
this the oh that's she has a boyfriend
no they definitely they still do that
and so
i and i know this this might i think
there for at least for me there is a
pure separation
and i know this because i'm somebody
who's been sexually assaulted
by different people different parts of
my life but
jealous she was the one that did it i am
into rape fantasies
so that i mean you would think i would
not be into that you would think that
would trigger trauma but eroticism is
eroticism like that
that goes into a different part of my
brain that does
not at all um draw memories
at least for me i know everybody is
different but
it doesn't trigger the things that have
happened in my past
yeah i used to be like that and then now
i was watching the hills have eyes
instead of the election which felt very
similar
but the [ __ ] rape scene like horror
movies i think they're
like it almost feels like it's on
purpose that they're such bad acting
usually because
you need it to be bad acting because the
acting was so good in the [ __ ] rape
scene that i was like
can we turn this off i have like ptsd
twitching for a week now i'm like i
but i really have noticed the things
that i think i'm cool with
um i have i just have ptsd and then i
because i'll have physical like twitches
and stuff i'm like oh and it's like
you know i think i'll be over something
and then i'm not so i just don't even
and my mom was always
my mom was not sexually assaulted or
anything but she always was like i hate
gory things and i was always like oh
come on [ __ ]
my dad would always take me to like was
she murdered
what was she murdered okay i don't think
that that's analogous though saying
that oh you were sexually assaulted but
you like rape fantasies like i don't see
that correlation to like oh he wants to
punch me while we're having sex it does
seem to be like a difference between
a guy going in wanting to rape
right so here's another thing i think
it's a matter of like
con you know consent too it's like if if
army hammer is going in there and that's
just the one thing that he gets turned
on by
but the partner is not on board but he
somehow overpowers her
or kind of forces her to be on board
then that can get a little bit hairy but
if if all
systems are a go and she's engaging in
this
um i just think that you know it's we
shouldn't necessarily like that that's
like thought crime right
like we would be like persecuting
thought crime and i don't think that
that's right
do you think that we are judging
cannibalism
um with um american lenses
sure i'm oh i'm only a i'm american
yeah so i'm always judging everything
through my lens and the cannibalism
makes me uncomfortable
and i think i am kind of allowed to
right
yeah totally no and i think that look
i'm i'm not
i'm not you know foaming at the mouth
wanting you know a chunk of bobby's
thigh any
day now but like you know in other
cultures is it because of that green
foot
exactly that that's what i want that's
another story i want to tell you
you know clock that annie because i have
a a story about that but let's say in
like papua new guinea right
up until the 1950s um they would
eat their dead what was a sign or a show
of like respect and honor like when a
person
that's how expensive the funerals were
getting they're like let's just eat them
[ __ ] it so let me ask you guys this then
esther
um so in papua new guinea up until the
1950s when it was considered
um they basically the world health
organization made it illegal because
the women and the children would eat the
brain exclusively and then they
developed this
um yeah this brain swelling encephalitis
that they called kuru
and and and basically the name of the
chicken is just
annie have some respect
my poor chicken but yeah they would have
kuru and people were
it it was basically like they would
almost like go mad from it
and then die and then um postmortem when
they would crack their brains open they
would see that the brain had really like
spongy texture and giant holes
and then they'd eat that and then the
doctors would go crazy right so
it like wiped out two percent of the
entire population but it was only men
and it was only women and children who
ate the brain why
um i don't know what their um rules were
so if you eat so if you eat human brain
your brain will get messed up and you
don't no no no
there was a particular prion a prion is
like an infectious protein
and um it basically they ingested that
from whatever sick brain
there was there was a prime there was a
pathogenic protein that was existing in
palau at this time
the people ate it they got it it's like
it's like mad cow disease we eat
a cow that has a prion
and we end up get going mad is that what
you call going down on annie
eating a cow that has a pry on a pry on
it's instead of a tr a strap-on i cover
my dick with a vagina it's called a
prion
if you were stranded on an island and
it's just you and todd annie and then
you and dave oh i'll kill lester
i'll kill her i would never eat her i
wouldn't disrespect my own body by
eating her i just kill her and let her
sleep
i'm not even on the island with you i'll
cut your
[Laughter]
what song is she thinking of that she
thinks that you could choose
um i think that's phil collins sasemudio
i can't i also get so humiliated when
people are like what's the song you're
thinking of him
i can't sing it i can't sing it it's
like one of the things that just
humiliates me that's so funny that you
you can get on stage and talk about your
[ __ ]
but don't oh because that's what my act
is
esther talks about sex on stage and
she's like i'm a pizza
she's like ah it's like so much more
offensive than anyone talking about
their vagina
esther if you're on an island with dave
yes
and dave has expired r.i.p you're crying
you're
really sad but you know she would make
dave right before he died to start
cutting his own leg up
to serve her
okay so you know it it's gonna be at
least
another month before you're even you
your smoke signals are seen or your
flare is seen by the
she doesn't need spam she's not going to
eat yeah first of all i would never be
on an island okay i don't travel well no
you guys were
flying over an island the plane went
down great now you were going to skokie
and they had to take a weird turn
i'll never get on a plane again copy
that no i would not eat i don't think i
could do that i think i would just
commit to losing a lot of weight looking
awesome
and you know i'm i'm like almost vegan i
eat sushi but otherwise i'm vegan
i don't think i i mean can i just tell
you esther went through a baking phase a
vegan digging phase that was
really hard to get through she was like
i have cookies because she esther wants
you to come to her house all the time
so she has to give you little treats and
stuff to get you to come over she has to
trick you
and so then you get there and she's like
i bake cookies and it's like
the worst most disgusting thing and it
took me a month to even admit it that's
how i loved those cookies and i knew you
i could tell you didn't like them and
you like i didn't eat them but do you
lie
annie well she baked for me so i didn't
want to like i whenever esther does
anything
i want to encourage her because i'm so
shocked that she's these cookies were so
fluffy they were
she made them like esther like was like
i have a plan
i'm gonna follow this recipe i'm gonna
get all these ingredients dave will pay
for them but i will do it
and then i will force him to eat and
dave has been battered down by her for
so many years that he's like
they're good i'm like no one thinks this
is good
but we're excited that she's
experimenting she's trying she's getting
out there
so one month you would just wither away
would you eat todd annie
um there's no way todd would die before
me there's no way
are you kidding protect me you would die
by protecting me
no matter who you're on the island with
you're the last one standing
i think so too you're so meaty
i would be one of those girls at the end
of um my season of survivor i would not
i would look regular
can i give you a confession when we had
our falling out for three years
i was and i didn't see you we didn't
when we are falling out we didn't even
see each other but we lived
one street away from each other yeah
wait what why was the falling out what
happened
you tell it well there are two things
happened so
we had we were fasting happened no
because we had just had the podcast
thing too because that was like that
week
and so 2013 was a falling out it's 2013.
yeah we had been friends for like a year
maybe even not a full year not even a
year like
but honestly dave and i were like hot
and heavy we just started dating and
then he wouldn't move in with me
and so i had this was like my first are
you heavy in that and he's hot
so i had to kind of like step away from
dave and you know
play the game away play the game to get
him to agree to move in
i met esther she was living in amy
cheapo who is a
uh does she do comedy anymore no i think
she's in q anon now
she's in kyunan she's a q and comedian
she was living in her
amy had she's a avocado heiress or
something i don't know
she had something she told us all the
time but she so
she we shared a studio apartment
together now
esther just had a small single bed in
the corner of someone else's nice
it would have been a great studio
apartment had you not been
in the corner it was my place first and
she came in and cleaned it up and made
it hers
that's so funny and you took the corner
you love being the little thing
that's right you're sick you're sick
but like amy had like a huge bed it was
nice and fluffy and then she was in the
corner
and amy would like cook and clean for
her and take care of her
and i remember you had met dave and dave
was like writing on something dave was
like making good money and you were just
like
we should live together why am i sharing
a studio apartment with a grown woman
two grown women one weird choice by the
way it wasn't like this
opportunity happened and she made it up
and dave wasn't ready to move in
he's going to kill me for talking about
this i can't believe i'm doing this on
the first episode he doesn't want me to
talk about him at all
and so i had to like you know lay low
and then eddie danny perfect annie and i
go fast and hard this is perfect like
i'm
trying to give the guy space i got annie
got a new guy
new guys in town we're going hard and
fast anyways we're going to runyon every
day
we basically i we have a mutual friend
and i go to
this mutual friend's house i was like
driving in the neighborhood from a
meeting
stopped by we have like i walk in it's
me and him it's kind of i just point out
you said from a meeting
it was a meeting you just want to let
everyone know i
hollywood meeting not a ai so
we're talking for like 10 or 15 minutes
and all of a sudden annie
walks out of the bathroom and they were
talking near the bathroom and i'm like
near the door oh it was it was this
guy's studio whatever studio apartment i
was like
oh what so you're just hiding in the
bathroom
at while i'm speaking and i don't know
you're there it's it's a three-way call
from junior high right
yeah what do you think they didn't ask
me what do you think about any but it's
it's that it's like
what do you think about annie she's on
the other line like
it was that yeah experience and i was
just like shady walks out of the
bathroom like what and then esther's
like you know i don't like surprises i'm
like i don't i just [ __ ] met you
no i wasn't even like angry i was i was
more like wait no you were so mad you
stormed out you were so mad why
was it on the phone no it wasn't a phone
she was just saying it was
like when you you did when you would do
those three oh
but this i don't think you guys had
phones where you grew up no no not a lot
we also had three
like when you had a phone number it was
only three numbers but so listen to this
so this ad like when someone was on the
other end of the conch show
i literally remember my childhood number
eight five five three three
there was no area code nothing but go
ahead esther
so we are i'm pissed right so annie and
i
we don't speak for three years because
i'm like
why is she so [ __ ] mad i had no i'm
like why is she hiding in the bathroom
why are you guys mad at this listen
listen listen listen okay so we we fall
out we don't speak for three years
we reconnect because i think i asked you
to be on cocktails that web series
i don't know i i just remember being
like what am i doing i can't remember
how we came back together it was pretty
fast it was just instant we realized
this was stupid
so we come back together we're friends
for a while and then it takes like
almost like six months of being friends
again to be like wait
why were we mad at each other it's the
monkey in the middle
who told me to hide he goes oh my god
esther will think this is so funny
like literally because we had been
friends for we were hot and heavy but it
wasn't
i didn't know yeah we didn't know each
other that well and that and then i'm
like
he knew that i don't like surprises he
knew that i would be so uncomfortable if
someone was
hiding and i didn't know so now we're
just like oh the falling out was not
let me get this straight guys you guys
fell out because someone was hiding and
and someone didn't like someone hiding
and popped out of nowhere
yeah we also though i mean the podcast
thing had
happened and i was i think i was pretty
resentful i don't remember that but
essentially we were gonna start a
podcast and i guess i pulled out but i
don't remember why i pulled out i had it
was our
we we recorded two episodes which we are
we would really like to find if we could
find
because it would have been good we've
always had it it was going to be called
esther nanny make out
or anything yeah we're just like let's
play on the fact that we're girls and um
did esther choose that name probably
i don't know but it did not it was not a
hard name to come up with
it was very honestly we either would
if we had continued that podcast we
either would be so successful
or dead no murder suicide like dead i
just it was we were not ready
like i we were not ready to do that i
believe that i believe we're ready now
eight years later
[Music]
okay so before we came here today we
decided to all prepare
questions that we've always wanted to
ask each other but haven't asked yet
i'm gonna go first so the the questions
i have
are let me preface it these are
questions that if you
have the same answer as the person
you're dating
it means it's a really good sign you
guys are compatible
okay wait so what esther is trying to
say is she didn't come up with these
questions she got them from something
else no i don't
no well those are quite just wait
do you like roller coasters i hate them
ugh i love them i'm so sick of everyone
hating them
i've i've had so few people in my life
recently that like
the last two guys i dated hate roller
coasters that's why you broke up with
them and
and really that's a it's a dave and i
both hate roller coasters and
that's like a good thing bobby loves
them so even though i hate them i get on
all of them
you do you're so nice all of them how do
you handle that
um i just suck it up put my big girl
panties on and have heart palpitations
for nine days after the one time i went
on a roller coaster i remember thinking
i would rather jump off the seat to my
death yeah cause it's more exciting
i would rather do that too it's more
exciting okay next question that's very
similar
if you will probably have the same
answers do you like scary movies
i like the camaraderie of watching scary
movies with people because i think
that's i have
but i would never watch him alone so
the answer is probably no annie
i used to love them i do like being
scared i like all that stuff but i
have recently todd's really into them
i'm like can we stop watching horror
before i go to sleep
but then i'm like let's put on a
dateline i want to say a real one day i
like daily and i don't like scary movies
i don't like a jump scare i don't want
to feel scared
yeah i love that you are like a freak
you're like
you are like bobby no there's a whole
genre drug addicts that could be
yeah that's what it is it's a drug
addict it's the adrenaline
do you believe in ghosts no absolutely
and mind you i am a science freak
and there's no way that i could ever
explain again you're wearing your i
believe in ghost outfit
but no i i i absolutely believe in it
because i think i was raised like
catholic you cannot not believe in
ghosts if you've been raised catholic
yeah i understand that i feel like i i
don't want to say like heart i just the
when the people with the things and
they're having like metal detectors yeah
i'm just like
this is the most ridiculous but i do
believe that when you die you like
fizzle into the infinity of it all and
you're still here
and you're you're i believe in ghosts in
the sense that our parents
and our ancestors are all within our dna
and we're all part of them so we're
living
on through that i just think they exist
to torment us
like that's the only way that i believe
in ghosts like i don't think of it in
you are a ghost esther
i know do you believe in ghosts i want
to
but i kind of don't like pretty girls
like
i really want to and i just it's like
hard to but sometimes i try to feel like
energies wow that's what she calls
genitals
i try to feel them wait my last question
is if you were to go back to college
tomorrow what would you pick as your
major
i know mine you go annie oh i would save
that money i would take that money and
run
are you [ __ ] kidding me i was in
college for eight years my college went
out of business two weeks ago what did
you major in
uh counseling psychology my mom wrote
all my papers i don't know if the e
or the u comes first and freud like i
have no clue
i i hated it i had panic attacks all
night every night
i never got my work done and then i
suffered over it i felt like such a
failure such a loser
my parents like right before i graduated
they were like
you we don't care if you graduate or not
like you can just like the jig's up if
you want and then i was like no i have
to i
put this like pressure on myself that i
would be a loser if i didn't graduate
and now i'm like
everyone i respect not i do not respect
you so
just be careful but um be careful what
you do next
no but a lot of the people i respect
didn't go to college
or graduate college finish yeah god
go you esther what would you i think i
would
i know it's just like a cheat answer but
i think i would want to be a dance major
and
i was as a joke gonna say dance what are
your guys's questions
you want to go in here sure mine are not
like that those were good
what was the first time you got dumped
like where your heart was broken dumped
and how did you retaliate and how did
you come back from it
i got dumped in high school i was
working at johnny rockets and i got my
boyfriend
oh now we know how you got why you got
dumb no no no no i got him a job at
johnny rockets and then he started
dating
the new hotter waitress at johnny
rockets and did you did you get him
hired there so you could keep an eye on
him
i got him hired there so he would make
money
and that too kind of it's completely
backfired it was the
worst worst scenario so i had to quit
and i still miss my managers there
because they were so
they babied me um
i never really i think like my
retaliation is like
my whole [ __ ] career i
i'm so pissed still you're like listen i
bought a six flags you guys are gonna be
so jealous
yeah i was i couldn't it was like the
first time in my life where i couldn't
eat i was such a mess
but did he come up to you and go i'm
dating this girl no he lied
no so you broke up with him no he dumped
me and i found out later why
they always hide it you know they're
like oh it's time to break up and it's
like no you
[ __ ] french why is this french girl
at my johnny rockets at an orchard mall
get the [ __ ] out of here was she uh um
like an exchange student or was she
probably i i don't know i've never
officially been dumped
i've just been rejected a lot oh my god
we have to get bobby for the show to
dump you
bobby's never been dumped in his life
either what but he also feels
very similar to me he's also just been
rejected a lot i think the worst
heartache i ever felt was the first time
now
i realized that he was a full-blast
narcissist but i was
22 he was 37 he was a really
good-looking um tattoo artist but just
not a tattoo artist he did specifically
a filipino tattoo art a filipino tattoo
so he was like a historian yeah
and he likened himself a poet a writer
all of these things that a 22 year old
would be so impressed by because we
don't
have a lot of life experience did he
smoke cigarettes um
he didn't but he had both those nostrils
peers
equal that's the equivalent it is um and
um he cheated on me
with a tattoo client that i had booked
for him
and i found out because i got um
a really bad bacterial infection when he
came back from
in the chinese in the up in the vaginis
and it was really she got it in her ear
it was so weird
and i remember but they role played that
she's the
her ears the vagina and
um i genuinely um
i remember my vagina burning really bad
and i remember confronting him saying
i could either go to the doctor and
confirm i got i caught an sdd
or you're going to tell me the truth and
he told me the truth
and i pretended to take him back anyways
and forgive him
because i needed my own way of ending
things and retaliating
so two weeks go by and um
one night i decide that i'm gonna clean
the house
cook dinner do the laundry and then i
left and then i never came back
and i i blocked him let did not give me
that's so
good what did you do you said is gonna
have to figure this out so
that's a good move that is like when he
got comfortable again i was like
just kidding go [ __ ] yourself forever
and then disappear for someone's life is
so good we must do it
bye annie
when when did you get them i got dumped
when i was 14
so hard and it sounds young but i was
[ __ ] you know so it was like
wait what what age did you lose your
virginity when i was 14.
very um eastern european it was i
everyone else i thought it was so normal
i was so pissed when i found out
everyone else waited like i was like are
you kidding i thought i was like a late
bloomer
you mean i had the option to say no i
was i lost my virginity on this guy
brad's water bed
in northeast philadelphia off of
philmont avenue was it
water supplied by you certainly not my
tears maybe
it's certainly not i was so i hadn't
even like touched his dick i was just so
pressed peer pressured
and um yeah his mom would come down and
my nipples pierced his mom would come
down
the laundry room he lived in the
basement in the water bed and then
the laundry room was across the hallway
in the basement that was the whole
basement
so but then he just had a curtain set of
a door so she would come down and just
like to do laundry and pop her head in
and he was like a wigger which maybe
we'll have to take that out but
there's no other word for it sorry and
he would wear his pants like
low under his ass he wouldn't get naked
he would just pull his dick out because
his pants were already that low
so he would throw his clothes on and
then i would just be naked there i'm
like
what what does this look like are you
drawing me you [ __ ] talentless
[ __ ] loser and so he we dated for
eight months i was so
he was so mean to me i was so in love
with him we would smoke out of two liter
bottles he turned into bongs
we'd like blasting dmx he had a neon
a red neon chrysler neon under the
chryslers and he was like so low back
in it he would be so low in it with his
head that you could only see like the
little
nub on the top of his baseball hat and i
was like he's so cool and he would just
have one thing
and we smoked newports together and i
just thought that we were like
i was like he may be an [ __ ] but he's
my ass i was so in love with him
and then he broke up with me after we
went on a school trip to mexico which is
an
entire episode of the show i will tell
that mexico trip
he broke up with him because he said he
didn't like the way i treated my best
friend on it which is
another episode you were allowed to go
to mexico
with my juvenile delinquent school in 14
yeah okay with my juvenile delinquent
school
by the way every teacher was like
i mean almost everyone was right i feel
like you're caught as
as a child molester almost all of them i
feel like that should be
three episodes yeah that's a big that's
a big one but the retaliation was so
then he started dating my
he said that he didn't like the fight i
got him with my friend
which was so crazy i'm like what are you
talking about so then they
so then they ended up dating behind my
back for months and then the
disciplinarian at the school told me
she had gone to another school and she
was like called to say hi because they
were all friends with us and
all the teachers were friends with all
the students yeah good friends
um and then she was like how are you
dealing with like hannah and brad dating
and i was like what
and the whole school had known except me
for months
that they were dating and so i called
her and her dad was like she's an
[ __ ] i'm sorry i told her to tell you
and then
i could hear him going like ow and the
mother was like beating him with the
spatula like how dare you not like take
her or whatever i'm like
but she there's no side or someone just
lying to someone and
so then i was just in hell at the school
i think i took like a month off where i
got tutored at home because i was just
like i can't go to school which by the
way
who lets a kid do that but um my school
was just like sure well dude
no might not what and then
i became friends with her again because
she was like i want to break up with
brad
like do you want to call like i'll do a
three-way call
so we did the three-way call and she
broke up with him and he was like so sad
it just made me feel so bad and i
i just like it wasn't there was no like
feeling of triumph
and then years later when i was 19 i did
the landmark forum with my parents which
is like a
there's like so so many things i know
i'll tell you i'll tell you the rest of
the story another time but
i called him to like i remembered his
number and i called him
to kind of be like i really took our
relationship seriously like we were just
kids i was 14 you were 16 like
young love haha and he pretty much was
like i'm really glad you called me
because
i felt so bad because i was always into
hannah and i never liked you and i was
like
oh we're breaking up i can't hear
anything it just backfired so hard i
thought he was going to be like
you were so hot you know what i mean
but he's been in and out of prison god
bless him shalom um you guys
thank you for listening she loves
wrapping up she doesn't like starting
she likes to write what do we tell them
to do like and subscribe do we even have
to say that i think annie does the whole
smash the button right yes
the button what do you got to say in the
beginning smash the button sounds like
sexual who smashes who's button in sex
you don't know i guess smashing a button
but you don't smash a button oh wait you
see i kind of do
you like look smash that like button
uh no you guys please click the like
button do we keep doing this
tell us do you like this do you want
more like it
subscribe [ __ ] comment if you've made
it to this part of the episode you like
it
comment follow us all on instagram it's
linked below
you guys we're gonna this is a bloodbath
and you this is all on tape for the
court
to see she's going down say bye to
esther everybody we'll see you guys next
week
bye bye kleila your delight [ __ ] you
just kidding love you ladies
[Music]
next week on bloodbath i'm wearing a
mask because there is a smell in this
room that is so vile
she almost threw up and that's just part
of it kalila makes me face
the infamous kyle do they become friends
forever
or do they become mortal enemies and can
she do a squat
i think you already know the answer
we'll see you next week guys